let's have some practice adding and
subtracting negative numbers so the
first example I want to look at is two
minus three so right now I'm just
subtracting a positive number from
another positive number but you might
already see that I'm subtracting a
larger number from a smaller number so
I'm probably or I will definitely end up
with a negative number let's just think
about this a little bit and I'm gonna do
it with the number line so there's my
number line right over there now this is
0 this is 1 this is 2 this is negative 1
this is negative 2 we could view this as
starting at 2 so this is 2 right over
here and then we're gonna subtract 3
from that 2 so we're gonna move 3 to the
left on the number line so we're gonna
move 3 to the left
1 2 3 and that gets us to negative 1
this is equal to negative 1 now let's
mix it up a little bit more let's
imagine what we would what would happen
if we had negative 2 negative 2 minus 3
so this was positive 2 minus 3 now think
about negative 2 minus 3 so once again
let's draw our number line and I'll put
0 over here so this is 0 this is 1 this
is negative 1 negative 2 negative 3
negative 4 negative 5 negative 6 and I
could keep going but we're starting at
negative 2 starting at negative 2 and
then we're subtracting 3 again so once
again we're gonna move 3 to the left of
negative 2 so we go 1 2 3 we end up at
negative 5 so this is negative 5 so
notice in both situations we subtracted
3 we moved 3 to the left on the number
line
it's just here we started 2 to the right
of 0 here we started 2 to the left two
to the left of 0 this is negative 2
let's do another example with these same
with these same numbers let's imagine
negative 2 negative 2 plus 2 I'm sorry
plus 3 I encourage you to pause this
video and try to think about this on
your own so will you draw the number
line again
I could draw a straighter number line
than that so draw the number line again
now let's say that this is negative 2
negative 1 0 1 & 2 again we're starting
at negative 2 we're starting to to the
left of 0 so we're starting at negative
2 and we're gonna add 3 so we're gonna
go 3 to the right now 1 2 3 and we end
up at positive end up at positive 1 now
let's think about now let's think about
2 so positive 2 and we're going to
subtract a negative 3 so we're gonna
subtract negative 3 and other videos
we've already talked about this in fact
there's a video explaining why this
actually makes sense but when you
subtract a negative this is same this is
the same thing as adding the positive so
2 minus negative 3 is the exact same
thing as 2 plus 2 plus positive 3 these
two statements are equivalent and this
is just boils down to this right over
here is just going to be 5 now let's mix
it up a little bit more let's imagine
negative 2 let's imagine negative 2
minus negative 3 minus negative 3 now
this might seem really intimidating I
have all of these negatives in place
here but you just have to remember
subtracting a negative like this is
going to get you a positive so this is
the exact same thing as negative 2 plus
3 and negative 2 plus 3 we've already
seen it right over here you start at
negative 2 you start to to the left of 0
and then we're going to go 3 to the
right we're adding 3 1 2 3